ahora que hemos establecido nuestras
ecuaciones veamos si podemos contestar
algunas preguntas interesantes y a
manera de calentamiento voy a hacer lo
que hice en el vídeo pasado pero lo voy
a hacer con las ecuaciones las
ecuaciones son representaciones
matemáticas de lo mismo que tenemos acá
arriba con palabras a manera de
calentamiento calculemos entonces bajo
el plan básico cuál sería el costo de
asistir a tres sesiones en un mes dado
bien tenemos aquí nuestra ecuación el
costo total va a ser igual a 20 más
20 + 8 por el número de sesiones el
número de sesiones es 3 sustituimos el 3
en vez de la s iba a ser 8 por 3 nuestro
costo total para tres sesiones sería 20
+ 8 por 3 20 más 24 que es 44 vamos a
ponerlo acá arriba deja de borrar esto
primero así es que por tres sesiones
pagaré 44 dólares ahora hagamos lo mismo
para el plan de prueba cuánto nos
costará asistir a tres sesiones
aquí el cálculo es más directo el costo
total el costo total se es igual a 12
12 por el número de sesiones en este
caso el número de sesiones es 3
sustituimos en vez de la s 3 sería 12
por 3 el costo total es 36 dólares
vamos a ponerlo acá arriba borro primero
esto el costo total de asistir a tres
sesiones bajo el plan de prueba es 36
dólares pero también podemos responder a
preguntas más interesantes con estas
ecuaciones como por ejemplo a cuántas a
cuántas sesiones a cuántas sesiones
puedo asistir a cuántas sesiones puedo
asistir por digamos que tengo digamos
54 dólares 54 dólares ya tengo mi
presupuesto en base a lo que gano pude
determinar que lo que tengo para ponerme
en forma con acondicionamiento físico
son 54 dólares y quiero saber de acuerdo
a cada plan a cuántas sesiones pueda
asistir pagando esa cantidad empecemos
con el plan de prueba a cuántas sesiones
puedo asistir por 54 dólares y
supongamos que
este es un estudio especial donde puedes
inclusive asistir a media sesión por
media sesión bajo este plan pagarías 6
dólares por un cuarto de sesión te
cobrarían 3 dólares se llevaría un
control de la fracción de sesiones a las
que asiste no siempre necesitarías tomar
sesiones enteras
podrías asistir a dos y media y te
cobrarían de acuerdo a eso habiendo
considerado eso podemos preguntarnos
bajo el plan de prueba a cuántas
sesiones puedo asistir con 54 dólares
pensemos en esto un momento ahora me
costo se es 54 dólares el costo mensual
se es 54 dólares 54 es igual a 12 12 por
el número de sesiones en las que pueda
asistir 12 por eso ahora que establecido
esta ecuación para contestar a esta
pregunta debo de encontrar cuál es el
número de sesiones s que cumple con esta
ecuación ahora que esa es la incógnita
cuál es el valor de ese que multiplicado
por 12 nos da igual a 54 y aquí fíjate
si dejamos a la s sola del lado derecho
vamos a obtener la solución pues ese va
a ser igual a algún valor y para dejar
sola a la s del lado derecho vamos a
dividir este lado derecho entre 12 12 se
dividió entre 12 me va a dar ese me va a
dar el número de sesiones pero si tengo
un signo de igual y no quiero que se
altere es igualdad no puedo únicamente
dividir el lado derecho entre 12 también
necesito dividir entre 12 el lado
izquierda si esto es igual a eso para
que se mantenga esta igualdad tengo que
hacer lo mismo a ambos lados de la
igualdad así es que del lado derecho nos
queda tan solo la s y del lado izquierdo
nos queda 54 entre 12 a ver veamos
cuántas veces cabe 12 entre 54
no voy a hacer por aquí arriba 12 que
divide a 54 no veamos 54 entre dos es a
44 por 12 48 los restamos 54 unos 48 6
es decir 54 entre 12 me da cuatro y me
sobran 6 vamos a escribirlo aquí 54
entre 2 es igual a 4 enteros
62 ya vos lo cual es igual a 4 enteros
s el número de sesiones a las que puedo
asistir son cuatro y media el número de
sesiones a las que pueda asistir con 54
dólares bajo el plan de prueba son
cuatro sesiones y media si este fuera un
estudio que dijera no puedes asistir a
fracciones de sesiones en ese caso
podría afirmar que lo más que puedo
asistir son a cuatro sesiones para no
salirme del presupuesto pero hemos
aceptado que se pueden asistir a
sesiones fraccionadas así es que pueda
asistir a cuatro sesiones y media ahora
contestemos esa misma pregunta para el
plan básico bajo el plan básico a
cuántas sesiones puedo asistir por 54
dólares bien de nueva cuenta este va a
ser nuestro costo total para ese mes
así es que aquí tenemos que ese es igual
a 54 lo cual es igual a 20 más 8 por el
número de sesiones 20 más 8 por el
número de sesiones y de nueva cuenta
quiero dejar solo a las sesiones del
lado derecho para que pueda decir bueno
sesiones es igual algo obtener así el
número de sesiones a las que puedo
asistir pero
este 20 aquí y este 8 aquí y tengo que
pensar cómo deshacerme de ellos lo
primero que voy a ver es cómo quitar
este 20 del lado derecho y eso va a ser
algo que tengo que hacer para toda la
ecuación lo más fácil para esto es
restar 20 del lado derecho pero si restó
20 del lado derecho
tengo que restar 20 también del lado
izquierdo para mantener la igualdad y
que me resulta de esto bueno del lado
izquierdo 54 menos 20 es 34 y del lado
derecho bueno hemos hecho todo esto para
deshacernos del 20 y solo nos va a
quedar 8 ese así es que 8 veces el
número de sesiones es igual a 34 para
que 8 veces el número de sesiones más 20
sea igual a 54 puedes sumar 20 ambos
lados de esta última ecuación para
obtener la original ya casi hemos
terminado nos falta tan solo despejar la
s de aquí y cómo puede suponer lo más
fácil es dividir el lado derecho entre 8
y si dividimos el lado derecho entre 8
también tenemos que dividir
el lado izquierdo entre 8 y entonces
cuál es ese número de sesiones a las
cuales podemos asistir del lado derecho
los ochos se cancelan y obtenemos que el
número de sesiones es igual a 34 entre 8
y 34 dividido entre 8 es igual a veamos
8 cabe cuatro veces en 34 y nos quedan
dos octavos lo que es igual a cuatro
enteros un cuarto así es que puede
asistir a cuatro sesiones y un cuarto
bajo el plan básico así que suponiendo
que pueda asistir a sesiones
fraccionadas por 54 dólares cuál es el
plan que me permite asistir a más
sesiones el plan básico o el plan de
prueba lo que hemos encontrado al
resolver nuestras ecuaciones es que por
54 dólares puedo asistir ligeramente a
más sesiones bajo el plan de prueba